I think there's been nothing like this
before and it was high time that we had
an Old South Asian cast and a show that
kind of made South Asian kids feel feel
seen and heard and and those so it was a
no-brainer and plus the character was so
loving and kind and loyal and and and
and gets to be part of like solving
mysteries but the Royal detective so so
yeah I had to be part of it I love the
idea that I get to to kind of like rule
this kingdom with empathy and kindness
it is true that it is a first of its
kind right so I mean because so I was
just talking to Lila yeah and she was
saying her parents generation didn't
have anything like this for their you
know so tell me about that being a
first-of-its-kind yes I even growing up
even in India we never had a show that
was international that was going to be
viewed by everybody because in India we
did have a lot of Indian animated shows
but they were all Indian folk tales and
fables that was made for India alone but
this will be the first one that kind of
has as global reach and and in that
sense I feel it's really an important
time as well because you know with
technology and with kids being on even
just social media for example at a very
very early age there's so much curiosity
about cultures and about other
ethnicities and and their festivals and
what they eat and what they wear and in
a way to kind of almost normalize it so
it doesn't feel like it's it's a it
sticks out like a sore thumb because it
isn't where a 1.2 billion people and
every sixth person in this world is an
Indian is South Asian so so it's kind of
it's kind of in a way empowering almost
to the culture and to little kids from
of South Asian descent and so yeah I
think it's it's it's great on that level
and then another level it's it's
inclusivity right you're not just going
to be it's not just gonna be South Asian
kids watching the show it's gonna be
it's gonna be kids of all races and all
ethnicities but also parents and
grandparents and aunts and uncles and
nieces and nephews and the whole family
comes to watch this together and so I
really also also do love that the themes
are kind of it's important the themes
are around built around a lot of
compassion and kindness but a lot of
common sense and and kids don't want to
be just fed stuff that is childish you
know they want stuff that is that they
they go yeah I could solve these
mysteries as well I have common sense as
well and so I think it's it's empowering
on that level as well they're not taking
their intelligence for granted
did you get did you do all of your work
by yourself yes yes that's how we work
unless and until you know there is check
it's a scene partner like chiku and Miku
probably had to do it together or I
don't know if they did it together but I
would assume the two Mongoose wouldn't
do it together but I did all my scenes
by myself but I'd see the other cast
mates going in and out of the studio you
know before me or after me because Hough
I mean it's got great names yeah so I
guess you're gonna meet him soon or yeah
no Hannah and Cal and I have already you
know I know Hannah and Hannah Simone and
Calvin and I bumped into each other
recently and I was like I hope you're
coming to the premiere he's like I think
I'm gonna be on on set somewhere but
we're all equally excited you know we
all know how monumental this is and how
very grateful that Disney jr. has put in
all this muscle behind it and it has
already been renewed for season 2 which
is pretty awesome that's what yeah
congratulations before it even debuts
you get a season 2 yeah so tell me about
what's the best part of doing as opposed
to a film you know at doing an animated
well the the the demand on your time is
a lot lesser it's it's you know you come
in in sporadic in spurts just to come
and shoot a couple of episodes it record
a couple of episodes and you go away you
go do other stuff and come back when the
other episodes are ready but but I think
the exaggeration that you have to bring
in when it's animation is very different
from how contained and
internalized acting for off a camera for
film
it's like film or television for that
matter but I think I think the
exaggeration was maybe a little daunting
the first two or three lines that I had
to first give him was like louder like
bigger okay this is really broad but it
kind of makes sense because all you have
is your voice to fit on these faces of
these amazingly cat you know drawn
characters animated characters so yeah I
think the exaggeration is probably this
the most stock difference between the
two you have a lot to celebrate there's
you got I was reading all the other
projects you have going and you're gonna
be an executive producer on a series
yeah and star in it yes so tell me about
a little bit about that if you can yeah
well there's not much that I can share
at the moment but I'll just say that it
was a book that I read about a year and
a half ago before I even you know kind
of got the rights but the e one got the
right side we partnered with them it's
just a book that I kind of felt again
much like Mira was a story that needed
to be told it's about a former US Marine
and she happens to be South Asian as
well and I feel like just from the point
of view of women in combat and women in
the front lines we don't see a lot of
film or television shows about it and so
there's this common misconception that
there's probably women are not fit
enough to be in the military or women
are not strong enough but they don't
have the stamina or the willpower or the
or you know the power to sustain
themselves and so I feel like on a
rather bug with the story really spoke
to me on many different levels not just
about women in combat but also her own
struggles getting to a place in her life
where she could finally claim her own
claim her narrative because it was
constantly being manipulated or being
dictated by other people her parents and
then when she went to when the
environment that she was surrounded by
so a lot of the stories that I'm working
on are really stories on about ownership
and claiming your own narrative and I
want to ask about producing behind the
scenes eat I mean that is my story about
that is my personal story the part
using element about claiming my own
narrative and an ownership because I
feel that control that I would need in
order to tell the stories that I really
want to tell tell the stories I've been
yearning to tell that no one has been
listening that these stories are
important can only be told if I take
total control and hence claim my own
narrative do you feel I've talked to
I've been doing interviews lately with a
lot of actresses who feel like this
might be kind of the best time mm-hmm
for working in this business do you feel
that way it's best and complicated
because of its competitive nature
because there are so many platforms and
there are there's just that much more
talent now has opportunity and it's all
lovely and it's amazing but now trying
to like kind of navigate your way
through that crowd and be able to stand
right in front of the line and say this
is the story I have and this is why I
believe in it and selling the story is
definitely a bigger challenge now so I
think it comes with both its I wouldn't
say there's a con to it but it comes to
this prose and its fair share of
struggle I wouldn't say the struggle has
gotten lesser it's just become easier I
was reading you've got a romantic comedy
coming-out film with Ron Howard directed
by John yeah I mean this got to be a
great time for you and you just got
engaged
so yes love to celebrate what you would
tell me about what's happening
listen I think I think it's all great
and I'm so happy that everything in the
career life is going well and the love
life is going well and you know the
health life is going well and I kind of
just like look at it as I need to make
each day count and not really I mean we
all plan for the future and we're all
thinking about the future and planning
what the next film is and whatnot but I
feel like given the fragility of life
that we've seen in there just from the
beginning of this year I think it's so
important that no matter what you're
doing that you can't you can have find
carve that moment in your life everyday
to just stay present and just be
grateful for what you have
so that's truly how I'm sad
just by being self-aware and being so
happy for shows like Mira Royal
detective I mean that is the now you
know it's happening tomorrow we're gonna
have a premiere and I'm super excited
for it